Buenos días para usted Ángela y
precisamente el discurso de Gutiérrez
fue uno de los más duros no solo por lo
que acabamos de escuchar de las palabras
tan fuertes que utilizó sino también
porque hizo un llamado muy enfático a
colaborar en la confianza entre los
países del norte y del sur global que
según dijo ha estado resquebrajada por
eso hizo un llamado a que se creara lo
que llamó un pacto de la solidaridad
climática para que los países
desarrollados den más financiación y más
dinero a los países menos desarrollados
y que estos países más ricos han
incumplido su promesa de lograr los 100
mil millones de dólares cada año como lo
prometieron en 2009 por eso Gutiérrez
dijo también que este pacto debe ser
para poner fin a la dependencia de los
combustibles fósiles y dijo que los
países de la osd deben dejar estos
combustibles para 2030 y el resto de los
países para
2040 y dijo que la crisis climática es
lo peor que enfrenta la humanidad en
este siglo unas palabras distintas a las
del presidente de egipcio abdelfata el
Sisi quien si bien dijo que era uno de
los mayores inconvenientes se concentró
sobre todo en la guerra en Ucrania ya
que Egipto es el mayor importador de
trigo en todo el mundo y cerca del 80%
del suministro lo trae de Rusia y
Ucrania de allí la necesidad que tiene
de acabar la guerra y de contribuir a
que esta guerra termine
Marina y también un saludo para ustedes
cuéntenos por favor paralelamente la
intervención de los jefes de estado y de
gobierno que otras actividades están
planeadas para hoy y qué resultados Se
esperan
Pues hay tres eventos importantes a
Resaltar el primero la reunión entre el
secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez y el Primer Ministro
de Pakistán Mohamed sheval sharif que
hablarán seguramente acerca de las
desastrosas inundaciones que ha sufrido
Pakistán que recordemos es un país que
solo contribuye con el 1% de las
emisiones y sin embargo como hemos visto
un tercio del país quedó bajo agua
debido a esas Fuertes lluvias derivadas
del calentamiento global se espera que
el Primer Ministro pida como bien decía
María Clara el tema de la solidaridad
climática es decir que esos países más
responsables se pongan a trabajar para
ayudar a estos países que más están
sufriendo los daños sobre todo que estos
daños como bien decía aumentan a unos 40
mil millones de dólares en Pakistán otro
de los eventos tendrá la amazonía como
protagonista varios activistas y líderes
indígenas y activistas ambientales
pondrán
puntos de fricción o las problemáticas y
también las soluciones para proteger el
80% de la amazonía antes de 2025
recordemos una amazonía que está en un
punto crítico ahora mismo después de
sufrir degradación de la tierra y
deforestación que está afectando al 26%
del territorio y finalizó con otro
evento que va a impulsar senegal y
España con la para promover la
resiliencia ante la sequía un evento al
que también se han Unido o sea una
alianza Internacionales El lanzamiento
de esta Alianza internacional a la que
se han Unido países como Honduras y
chile como bien sabemos llevan varios
años lidiando con una fuerte se